this week's episode of ear biscuits is
brought to you by Squarespace the
all-in-one platform that makes it fast
and easy to create your own professional
website or online portfolio
you know I'm think I'm gonna be using
Squarespace to use our URL internet
peanut butter it's been redirecting to
rhettandlink.com/store you want to start
selling peanut butter I I don't know I
just I'm gonna I'm gonna tool around
with it okay you look into that in the
meantime I let them know that they can
try out Squarespace for free without
even entering in their credit card
information and then once they're
convinced that they want to actually go
forward with this whole thing make sure
you get 10% off by using the offer code
R and L are aandl so you can visit
internet peanutbutter calm and it'll
just redirect a rhett and Link because
I'm I haven't done it yet I got to carve
out the time but you should also
immediately go to Squarespace calm use
offer code rnl now it's not for an ear
biscuit welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc
and I'm Brett it's time for another a
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet that's the roundtable
of dim lighting this week we have
Brittani Louise Taylor that's BLT not
the sandwich but the youtuber
extraordinaire music video spoofs
vlogging all types of stuff we talked to
her about her bouts with bullying
growing up how she took on Hollywood at
the young age of 19 and the
unconventional method she employed to
build her YouTube channel
unconventional you won't believe how
many videos she watched in her first
year on YouTube watched not made
astounding speaking of astounding I had
what they called the confused burrito
for dinner tonight I was there I heard
you order it and I was confused
well there's is that why it's called
confused burrito no well there's this
Mexican restaurant not too far from us
wolf that's not saying a lot we're in
Los Angeles but this is probably the
closest Mexican restaurant to our studio
and we've never been and we decided to
go to it
nice atmosphere by the way it was kind
of like Disneyworld Disneyworld
restaurant on the inside like doors to
nowhere windows to nowhere yeah barrels
with nothing in them yeah I loved it
no animatronics oh but on the illness I
always go for the special Errol's is
that like casks of whiskey tequila
tequila yeah I don't I always go for the
specials you know let me on the guy I
get the memory of when the Magrib comes
back I you know the grass is always
greener for you yeah and I mean if I if
the chef has taken the time to do
something a little bit different I'm
gonna take a chance with him even if I
don't know one and it is a chance that's
my perspective if the chef is trying
something new that's what he calls a
special this is especially new to me it
might be especially bad to you well it
was called the confused burrito and it
had great name by the chili Colorado
which is beef and red sauce on one side
and then it had salsa verde on the other
side and that was pork in green sauce
and I was like it's like a Christmas
burrito that was pretty exciting to me
and I got it but what was really
confusing to me is why I finished it
they bring this thing out now I just
ordered the carnitas go wrong go wrong
with that
yeah guacamole is like the barbecue of
Mexico
give me the carnitas hold the tomatoes
brought it out it looked great I looked
over it Rhett's plate and it was gosh it
was oh man it the burrito was so big it
looked like it looked like someone like
a doctor had operated it's like the
largest organ out of a very huge animal
and put it on a hot plate I mean it was
it had a couple of different color
sauces and it looked fleshy it was you
know it looked incredible I mean it just
looked like a burrito with two colors
but here's the deal I mean I don't know
what it is I don't know what it was but
I've always always without exception
finished everything on my plate well the
thing that I'm knowing this about you to
think the thing that I said to Rhett
people was before you started eating I
said can you picture everything that's
on that huge plate inside of you I
answered you not only can I picture it
but I will make it happen
you will picture it you will see a movie
of it just watch me do it see it I did
it I did it
that's what you know that's what hanging
out with me is like it's like constantly
being at a movie I ate it and I'm
beginning to regret that but actually
I've already regretted it three times I
am really sorry
if you know if you have to stop by I'm
not going to the restaurant so many
conversations here our bathroom related
know I hey you don't know what I was
talking about no I don't just don't
order the confused burrito because it
will confuse your your body it's just
the sheer volume of it confused your
body man you need portion control dude
you should have cut it right down that
part the demarcation between the red
sauce and the green sauce should have in
the place where you cut that thing in
half and then you could have had half
for later yeah but then I have wood it
wouldn't have been a two time a two tone
experience it would have been red or
green I wanted red and green well it's
interesting in segue into Brittani
Louise Taylor there is this confused
burrito nature to her start on YouTube
hmm
so you wanna see what I mean by that Wow
okay maybe it involved a character of a
different sauce and then her of a
different sauce a little bit later I
don't know just see if the analogy fits
is we get in this conversation here it
is our ear biscuit with Brittani Louise
Taylor
I shot a Hunger Games parody yesterday
and I was at the beach and like Katniss
costume and like everyone was laughing
at me because of like singing this I was
like there's a couple fart jokes and
lyrics in this catice costume with a bow
and arrow and I still ran into you know
keep the heat I ran into him he's like
oh hey Ella be like the middle of
nowhere like I'm at the beach only in LA
were you at the El Matador Beach yeah
that's the V I didn't know we shot on
that beach - okay cuz I need I needed
like I needed just a good location like
the One Direction I didn't know that oh
you're beautiful that's our little that
was right isn't it I think so but you'll
see it in a lot of videos where it's
okay we need a beach with like a rock
that has a hole underneath that looks
like kind of like Hawaii yeah yeah yeah
so we shot our ropes and bacon on it
there there's always something on there
because when we were down there there
was a guy shooting a model a bikini
model beach and we were like you know
what she was kind of she was in the
background of our robot yeah and we were
like you know what let's just leave this
she had on a thong I had never had a
thong in any of our videos this was not
a cover of the thong song which we've
which we've considered to a many times
this particular time it was an original
song like video a channel with Andre we
were I think he had some sugar and we
were just like laughing so we're like we
don't even know the lyrics and we were
just like both going back and forth and
like Dom likes Angeles I was like just
knew like one word and every lie that he
was singing it was brilliant so have you
ever had but cheeks in one of your
videos um no I think I've had yours or
anybody else's well I mean I've had pans
super-tight be probably like it probably
leaves a little to the imagination my
pants yeah like in the Katniss video we
just shot I was like woah okay they're
like Lululemon pants and like there's
leaves nothing to the imagination like
you can see
the cheeks and all their glory that what
the big controversy is they are they're
a little yeah
I didn't use a lot of butt shots okay
you kept it tasteful I do okay we kept
the butt shots and the long distance but
if you click on the actual girl yeah and
the background during that video it
brings up a hidden annotation of her
walking with the robot but we actually
did ask we asked her to put a shirt on
you know what just you know we we just
you know if a you know a two-year-old
anyway okay it was really funny we kept
trying to frame out this guy because we
want to shoot towards the water but
there's this guy that was scuba diving
in for lobster so you keep seeing his
fins come up and then the Kim come up it
dive back down so you're trying to frame
out the blobster guy I told you just go
dive off the coast of Malibu and you
could just get lobsters Wow he caught
like six of them now where his butt
cheeks exposed no we saw a lot of fun
lots and lots of fun not a lot of spin
yeah yeah and we like I had a lot of
people cuz you know at that beach they
have like you know the upper were like
the stairs are those thinking Mountain
well there's like everyone comes sitting
up there and watching us we started yet
like it's crowded like people like what
is she doing is I just bow and arrow and
I'm like lip-synching to these lyrics
here's a joke question though did you
get a permit no more I can't afford
permits we didn't either I mean I've
talked to many people who have shot it
elmatador and no one's ever got a permit
one direction probably did though I know
I think that I I don't know I mean and I
don't even know I'm one of those people
like I just fly by the seat of my pants
and I can film in different places and
we get in trouble we go somewhere else
like you know kind of light and I'm
super exactly I'm always super polite
and I'm super nice and the only time I
got in trouble a little bit we were
filming at the old Zoo oh yeah in
Griffith Park and I didn't I didn't know
that that's like that's like heavily
patrolled by the rain like the Rangers
because haunted
by the the ghosts of animals oh is it
yeah I didn't know this I didn't get
that like creepy vibe really good yeah
you weren't haunted you just were
crushed by a ranger just approached by
Ranger and I had a pink wig on and it's
like floral like full floral costume and
he was like you can't be filming oh I do
a permit we just ended up going up the
street and like running then filming in
the bush it's sort of like we just like
ran away but I got what I needed before
he kicked us out oh yeah that's why I
was gonna bring it back to butt cheeks
one more time but instead of doing that
why don't we just go back to go back to
your backstory
that's our back side okay not the back
side just the the back story where you
from I'm from Sedona Arizona
well I moved when I was one and a half
my brother is really allergic to
mosquitoes so he used to blow up like a
balloon and like in Minnesota where
we're from that's like the Minnesota
it's like the National birds like
mosquitoes everywhere we are in
Minnesota ah st. Paul st. Paul Twin
Cities one note one of the Twin Cities
yeah well yeah you can't have one way
all the other now your your laughter
sounds like a machine yeah
that's um it's it's a genetic thing my
brother does it to you it only happens
for like now I'm like totally
self-conscious about it it happens it
happens randomly and we call it the
machine gun can do it again like that's
not that's me trying but like it's what
I'm think something's really funny that
it usually comes out I either squeal or
a machine gun it's a little bit
frightening not both of the same time
okay so you and your brother do that are
you also allergic to mosquitoes I'm not
here so you got that gene but not the
other gene yeah okay yeah I got machine
gun whooshing laughter is both of us and
the mosquitos I'm I like you know the
bugs always liked Blake he's the one
that if we go campaign Blake's my older
brother so if we go camping he's the one
that gets eaten alive in two seconds and
it's covered like lotion this was so
serious that it required yeah he would
be relocation really would blow up like
just his whole body was just allergic so
and he was just a toddler and my brother
was 17 months older than me so he was
three at the time I was one-and-a-half
only Ally mom's like well the two places
we could go to or New Mexico or Arizona
for like not a ton of mosquitoes so we
lived in New Mexico first what is she
doing like talking to
how do you find this out is it I think
that I don't even know how you found
that really yeah exactly that was before
internet that was probably word-of-mouth
I'm sure now you probably go and Google
and put like you know cities without
mosquitoes but I think it was just
probably yeah a lot of word-of-mouth and
they wanted like a small community
someplace to raise us that would be safe
and and so what were your parents doing
at the time my my parents are so funny
my my dad was an airline pilot and my
mom was a flight attendant and then they
met on no but this is really funny they
met when they met on the plane my mom
would have never dated him she didn't
know that he was an airline pilot
because they were notorious players this
is like back and like they catch me if
you can kind of days for like pilots the
moment that came on the plane the
wedding rings like came off you know
that I don't thing and all the women
like my mom used to have to be like wait
in like he couldn't be five like pounds
over your weight your nails had to be
perfect like all the women were gorgeous
like that's that was like the actresses
of her day like everyone wanted to be a
flight attendant so she was just
literally they won't wait literally wait
literally you come in and if you were
five pounds over your weight limit you
could not fly well you do need to be
able to fit in the middle aisle I mean
I'm just that should be that should be
the realistic limit it shouldn't meaning
it should be a volume thing yeah but she
had to literally get notes from her
doctor because like she was allergic to
nail polish our whole family has
allergies so she couldn't wear it and so
she had to have like bring a note with
her and bring it with her to every
check-in or i'll she won't be allowed to
fly because her nails were painted it
was I do not accept service from flight
attendants okay well then you would not
like to my mom so they no they met on a
plane just as passengers and this just
that they were dating for two months
before she asked him like well what do
you do she said he's like I'm a pilot
just like no you don't know you're not a
pilot I don't date pilots so that she
had to go get his uniform to like prove
it to her but they they were married and
my mom was still working for a while
when she had me so I think when we moved
to Arizona she was still flying but then
she decided she wanted just you want to
be home with the kids it was too hard
but but they were able to just pick up
and move somewhere else because of the
way that the flight industry worked
because you just have to have a be near
a major city that you can be based like
my dad worked from Northwest so like
that there are certain places like you
at st. Paul was a base and like
was like a like a main station it just
had to be someplace that he could get to
wherever else he needed to go so there's
certain cities that you had to live near
and so I think that's part of the reason
they picked Arizona to you was that you
know it was close to Phoenix like an
hour and a half so your mom is allergic
to nail polish everything brother is it
she's allergic to everything everything
she's like literally she's the one like
when we're and like I was raised
Catholic and then like we just like
switch to stuff well like now we're just
like Christian I don't know she like you
know I'm Catholic they have the
incentive either ones like she's like
like hacking and her eye streaming and
have to run out when they do the incense
down the aisles like she we'd have to
sit back and she'd have to bring like
allergy medication and like sneak out
she can't handle it should have just
channeled that into like a big emotional
reaction and they're gonna be like look
how spiritual that lady is it's not a
Catholic Church in my understanding yeah
you do that at the Catholic Church they
kind of just look at you like that way
need to go to the Church of God keep it
in like it's all about keeping on the
inside right live with your pain no but
so yeah like our whole family has food
issues I don't know what do you have me
I've trained this is awful and I hate it
I have a tree nut allergy like which
means like I can't have like almonds
that any kind of nuts and I love nuts I
do I love like peanut butter tree nut
no peanuts that peanuts are actually a
fungus but like most people I know way
too much about food yeah back up a
second yeah peanuts are actually a
fungus they're not a nut you didn't know
that I thought they were a goon I don't
know I've heard they're fungus that's
something I'll have like the kind of
like I did you what does it called I
don't know I'm gonna say I am almost
positive that peanuts are not focus we
cannot go on the internet during an air
biscuit but I bet
peanuts can get fungus no I think that I
I've heard that they're fungicide
whatever I think if you smell like goo
backwards its
you're reaching I'm trying to help you
out you can't have almonds Brazil nuts
talk about a tree nut I mean this thing
the tree is just in the middle of the
rainforest and the truth they don't grow
them anywhere and they're like hundreds
of years old and they have these huge
pods that if they fall they will kill
you and they fall down and people
collect them and it's all every Brazil
nut that you eat in one of those packs
of trail mix you get it it was from some
tree in the rainforest
it is not harvested like a normal thing
it is in a freaking rakers Wow but
you'll never know about that because
you're allergic to it I will never know
about that and also what's the maca is
it macadamia nuts
or a nominee I'm trying to think that
cashews actually did you know they have
to be steamed to be opened so they're
like suspect also touched a little like
bacteria and fungus because that to get
them out you just steam them to get them
open like a kid okay yeah did you ever
have like I'm one of those really bad
reactions where do I get the EpiPen and
stuff I usually get no I've never had to
do EpiPen but I get like I'll get hives
I'm the one that then I get it like it's
weird we'll start more of my stomach
will start it changed it's always around
my stomach in that I get like this red
kind of hives just off in my body mmm it
happens randomly I'll be at a restaurant
and I'll be like oh don't know what they
put in there but it my body don't like
it yeah I got hives once in my crotch I
got hives in my crotch I went to the
doctor to get a check I want to hear it
and the it was one of those intern like
assistant person okay they got me to
drop my pants and took a look at it this
guy it was really awkward and then the
doctor comes in and
like okay I tell him the whole story
again and I start driving busy I don't
need to see and he just he just says
here's some antibiotics or something and
he didn't look at it and I was like well
that's really strange look at it but
then I felt bad that he didn't take a
look
was it a fungus it was I I think we did
that can't happen
then we did not determine what caused
the hives and it was hives so the doctor
just said well is it's probably stress
is it had never happened before never
happened again
[Laughter]
how did this happen I supposed to be oh
geez okay so you get you're allergic to
anything else um no I mean just like oh
you know sometimes like the perfumes
that are really strong I'll be it like
the post office and some woman will have
sprouts perfume and I will just be dyed
I'll have to walk out and my my eyes
will start streaming so I just it's just
I'm just sensitive to like awful perfume
thing ever life-threatening no minor so
your brother changed the trajectory of
your life yeah early age just to kind of
just kind of save him from swelling
exactly just well cause I mean the thing
is like you know especially when kids
were that young it's dangerous because
if he kept swelling up like what if his
you know his allergy gets more severe
and his throat starts to close when I
get stung or you know I mean it's not
like you need to get kids out of any was
happening regularly yeah yeah like that
the to the points they had to move
because he was getting eaten alive and
so how old were you when you moved to
Arizona what and a half one and a half
are in the desert I do my first memories
are like we had that all I remember it
was this real well we moved to Sedona
so it was 4500 and like feet is
elevation so it's like an hour and half
from Phoenix Phoenix is like desert so
where we moved to in stone it's all red
rocks red dirt it's like known for being
a tourist City like they have 22,000
people that live there now I think there
was like maybe 2,500 to 5,000 we moved
there and it was definitely a retirement
town and now it's just a full-blown
tourist town like they get like 8
million tourists a years and then crazy
it's a beautiful see the Red Rock just
you'll have to google it so don't know
like it's just it's it's been in a lot
of movies like it's just
just gorgeous but there's nothing to do
like it small tourist town so what did
you do what was life like like the grade
school Brittany growing up Oh God I mean
I think that I mean the good the good
thing about it I mean the bad thing was
there weren't a lot of kids and any kids
that you met our friends that you made
were usually Taurus and they're gone in
a week so I had a lot of friends that
were like from New York from Tucson from
Phoenix from other places that would
come in the summer for like a week or
come and then think that was really hard
but the Britney young because there was
nothing to do we spent a lot of time
hiking and we go to the creek a lot like
people don't know this but there's been
called slide rock and the locals know
not to go there because they get shut
down like multiple times a year fear
like a coli bacteria because people like
water so all the locals go down to Red
Rock crossing wood it looks just like
cleaner so I spent a lot of my summers
just like playing in the water and we
had one movie theater that's upstream of
where the tourists take dumps in the
wall it's downstream and way downstream
like it's all rinsed out by then because
like it's like way like many miles away
from where they all are doing their
business in the water but no when we
move there there was a place called
Bayliss it was bashes in palest but
together it was kind of like your
drugstore and your pharmacy and you're
like grocery store in one store okay and
then there's a place called the Flickr
Shack and there was this old guy that
hated kids but I had the only movies
hated kids so it was called the flicker
ship flicker Shack yet he was a movie
flicker right we would only play one
movie at a time and it would be there
forever and it was just one theater we
didn't have until I was in high school
was there actually Harkins came in with
seven theaters and that was like the
biggest thing to ever happen ona when we
got seven theaters that was like that
was huge oh yeah so you figure your
whole I mean your whole childhood there
and well like my mom she was a wheat
farmer so they had she grew up with
horses and I I wanted to get a horse so
partly I felt like five or six I think I
bugged her enough years she I got into
horseback riding so I grew up doing it
first I did like western pleasure and I
did some jumping like you know English
what is what now
Western pleasure it's like it's just
like a western pleasure there's a place
in Van Nuys I think
oh snap no no it's it's like basically
like we used to feel like they like you
know and that shows where they just like
walk trot and canter and like you try to
watch my picking up their feet like this
like kind of that's gated that's
different a little bit differently
they'll be like Tennessee walkers and
stuff like that so like but it's just
like when theyíre you walk you trot
let's say you walking another show
horses exactly yeah roping anything no
no I didn't do any barrel racing or
roping or any of that you jump over any
of those sticks I did I jumped over
sticks what's that called jumping great
gosh pretty heavily which is like it's
really boring it's it's in the Olympics
it's the most it's really boring to
watch it really hard to do it's kind of
like the easiest way to explain it is
like ballet on horseback so it's like
you have certain letters and you do
certain things that certain letters so
like a 20 meter circle would be like a
little circle in a little area or you
you know if the changes would be like
changing lead like from like like left
Lea to right lead it's like it's it's
really boring to watch and where you do
yes
yeah so I'd like I rode horses right all
the way up to 18 I was about 18 and I
grew up doing like sports and playing
tennis I was a total tomboy like really
like major tomboy well my brother was 17
months older than me and I idolized him
so it's like whatever he wanted to do
like I was I wanted to do so like you
know we played video games together we
always like be around each other we
always just got along school situation
are we talking about here school
situation was it was really strange
because it was such a small town and
like Arizona is like second worst in the
nation funding for education so
kindergarten was kindergarten was good
and then they pulled us out in first
grade we weren't learning anything it
was like naptime playing with clay so my
mom actually started to school in our
basement and then I was called
children's open school and I went to
school there for two years till third
grade and they hired at a school in Jars
basement started school homeschool yeah
a homeschool situation and we had 15
students they paid tuition they got a
gifted teacher to come in and it was uh
it was Brenda white cough if I remember
correctly but yeah I was two years I
went to school in my basement but it was
it was honestly it was great and I mean
they opened up the school to like and
you know they they had an interview
process with the parents but it was like
the parents had to do with it stuff with
the kids
once a week and then once a month there
was a group activity where we went
camping or we we were studying like
runes and we went up to Flagstaff
Arizona we did excavating like we got to
go into like where the ending you like
the dig sites and like you know dig up
pottery and whatever and all that jazz
so it was like we went to like Lowell
Observatory and stayed the night like it
was it was really cool like it was a
very like the school was very
interactive and it was an interesting
teaching method because you could do
anything he wanted all day but all there
was to do was educational activities and
you had to do one thing that had to do
with math or one thing they had do with
science but all the toys all the
activities were learning and there was a
there was one one teacher yeah who was
kind of making all this happen yeah and
then I think it was about third grade
that I just I really missed like I
wanted to I want to be around the kids
and my mom's like I'm saying your
school's socialized so I went back into
school system at third grade and then
just you know state and public schools
up until high school but I end up
switching I got it was pretty bad I had
pretty bad experiences in bullying when
I was younger so I had to switch schools
and so tell us about that what how old
were you when that happened oh god it
started just I mean my both my brother
and I were just like blonde hair blue
eyes just like you know like really tan
we're just nice kids but might because
my dad was an airline pilot and at that
time in Sedona it was just everyone
thought we were like you know filthy
rich and it's like no we're just in for
just middle class but like the median
income was not it was not what it is now
like now it's like multi-million dollar
houses everywhere but at that point like
you know they said that my parents like
overbuilt and they just built this just
like nice simple house like oh you over
built for Sedona so everyone like all
the parents I think a lot of it starts
with the parents the parents like well
you know thought my parents were rich so
then the kids thought I was rich because
my mom like you know she would like I'm
my clothes were just like Banana
Republic you know or something or the
gap like nothing nothing crazy but I
always had just like nice clothes or I
don't know so the the just I had a lot
of issues with like girls I had it was
really funny in kindergarten I had a boy
that kept writing my dresses and my
dad's like he showed me he's like next
time he does it just punch him so he
showed me like took me to bed we
practice so the next day you went ruin
my dress and I punched him so hard that
it it turned black underneath his eyes
both eyes both sides I actually yes both
eyes and trying to shove his nose and
well they hold a principle and then my
parents to come in for a teacher maybe I
was in kindergarten had to come in for a
parent-teacher meeting and we were at
the grocery store that night and this
guy like this little okay to us his mom
is like mom that's the girl that deck
the boy at school today but I'm confused
who was the bully well he kept ripping
my clothes okay I was left alone up
until like I left school like that you
know my dad was I would literally come
home every day was like rip clothes my
dad's like just duck him my dad's old
school he's from Canada he's got a
farmer he grew up in California my
parents were like they're like from the
mentality like you step on someone's
property shoot I mean like if you're not
sister B they're like they're like
they're all there literally like they're
they're just I don't know they're from a
different planet well if nobody was
stepping in you know if the teacher was
I know I'd say we tried that in the kid
well like would keep ripping my clothes
my dad's just like just duck him he
never did it again did he nope I was
left alone up until and then but then I
mean I left school and then just like
people thought I was like this so I like
even in high school I got like I had I
worked really hard and I saved and I got
an older BMW and I was making the
payment so I was working all summer to
you know make the payments on the car I
would come out and like people would
write like spoiled like bi TCH on my car
like I literally like wrote it on my car
like spray paint no they took like you
know what was dirty they just like they
basically scraped it in their fingers I
mean but it's just scratched the paint
but like the stuff like that happen all
the time but I feel like honestly I
always feel like it was a blessing
because it just made me stronger and I
think that I'm the last person to judge
people because I was judged my whole
life what do you think that was the
lowest point I mean I think what we'll
probably was really hard there was this
girl that was we finally got this family
that moved in on the other side where we
were at sky mountain there was this
auction where this house was foreclosed
and this family bought it this doctor
and he had like three Oh some three
daughters and a son and I became friends
with the oldest daughter and she had a
sleepover and I ended up being like the
first person to fall asleep and while I
was sleeping they poured nail polish on
me so I woke up in the middle of the
night and my skin I was like what's
going on like oh you knocked it off the
counter but I came out later they
ported on me because my mom like when
you know went back after them but I
literally had to call my mom go home she
did go get nail polish remover my skin
was bleeding it was really bad so I mean
I had but I had stuff like that all the
time I had I don't know just like girls
pulling my hair at girls and I am like
I'm not a person that's I didn't do
anything like they just would just pick
me out so I mean I got really bad in
junior high so I never having to go to a
separate school that was in a big park
which is like it's like 45 minutes Weiss
had to ride the bus 45 minutes and then
ride it an hour back every day to go to
school but I mean it may things got a
little bit better but then I had a curl
at that school the problem was that I it
was so random that's when I really
started getting into theater and acting
and they had Missoula Children's Theater
is like a traveling thing that comes to
town once a year it's really cool and
everyone comes like from Sedona
Cottonwood Camp Verde any of the
Flagstaff they'll come an audition it's
like a week-long thing where like in the
they put on a play in a week basically
so they had and everyone everyone wants
roles and it everyone wants to do it cuz
it's really freaking cool like they
bring the sets it's just all the
costumes it's amazing what they do in
one week but they had for The Wizard of
Oz they had auditions and out of it I
think it was 550 people or whatever I
got the role of Dorothy and then that
that caused a lot of problems it was
like I just had girls that just didn't
like me for whatever reason that was at
the the new school so it's just girls
and we're talking about a time before I
mean you know today there's all this
campaigns and so there's documentaries
about it there's movements organizations
this is before any of that yeah you know
how do you what do you think about the
way things are handled today and do you
wish that somebody had kind of stepped
in it helps you or you're like you know
what this actually made me who I am I'm
really glad that it I'm glad it happened
to me but I don't want it to happen to
anybody else does that make sense like
I'm I think it made me really tough cuz
I mean I moved I moved to Hollywood when
I was 18 by myself like I went on a
hundred and fifty student film auditions
before I booked a student film and it's
not that hard you know sometimes there's
like two people auditioning it's not and
I'm like I don't know I'm not doing a
bad job like I know some of them but
really well so I mean I think I was so
used to like people attacking me
rejection or whatever growing up that it
just felt normal like it was like oh
okay well this is this is life let's
like try got so used to knowing that you
just have to get up and try again and
get up and try again cuz like my mom
made me go to school like she made me
like you know go and she didn't let me I
mean she would give me she what she
called sanity today's like once a month
she would say that I had like you know a
doctor supreme or something she's giving
me the day off so she let me stay home
but but it was basically like torture
every day yeah I would come home crying
got better when I got into high school
because that's what I got really bad
acne and then the girls probably started
paint I used to be my skin was all
broken out so then I was like okay then
I wasn't so much of a target and being
in high school like by that point there
had Spence more people that moved into
the town that like quote-unquote had
money and again my parents were
middle-class but it was just like most
people were very low income so to them
they thought my parents were like filthy
rich so I think that was when like high
school actually got a little bit better
and I think to people start to mature a
little bit more and I think that the
difference between high school in grade
school is grade school they're gonna say
things to your face high school will say
it behind your back which I prefer a lot
more like talk about me behind your back
let just leave me alone okay what do you
say about be like just let me eat my
lunch so and your brother who you were
close to yes like a year ahead of you in
school yeah and so was was he was was he
a resource for you he um I think in high
school was good because you know we kind
of like you start to form like I hate to
say it's like a posse like you have
people that you hang out with in there
there's protection in numbers so when
you're around like you know we had all
like you know we've had land parties at
the house and that's when I started to
become like everything like more of my
friends were guys than girls because
girls girls can be catty sometimes guys
are more fun the things that I want to
do or usually guy things like I want to
go to the theme parks I want to go to
movies I'm not saying all girls are like
that but it's like you just it just
seemed to work out that way that I
wanted well they're having their dune
land party I wanted to hang out need
pizza with them so like that it just
ended up working out but I mean my
brother experienced a little bit of the
just the bullying like he had a guy like
throw a burrito at him and like almost
took out his eye like just like no that
was that was in grade school no I mean
it's just it was it like it's
interesting like everyone has their own
experience hasn't have gone through like
way worse but
that's your Sedonas and very interesting
town you know why though it's so
beautiful at this theory that people
move they're thinking it's gonna solve
all their problems and then they realize
they're wherever they go their problems
follow them so you end up having this
gorgeous place with all these crazy
miserable people that's what that sonoda
is it's all that we call them the like
there's all the nut jobs like they're
all nutty what do you think that the you
know the bullying that you were
experiencing you know you said you did
that you started theater and you started
yeah I'll try to be an entertainer were
those related no I think that I well
this is when I was four years old I saw
that Miss USA pageant and I literally
wore a bathing suit for four years of my
life like my mom let me shouldn't care
she's like so I mean I had to wear like
regular clothes to school but like any
other time like in the winter we had
pictures I have me with like tights in
the bathing suit and whatever like I
just I don't know I think I always like
wanted to be a performer without even
really knowing what that was and I never
like I haven't aspired to be like Miss
America are you saying about like
there's this place called tlaquepaque
that's like in Sedona and there's like a
little platform outside one of the
restaurants and my brother would go here
was bruiting and I go up there and sing
and dance and now there was a sign there
that says no performing on the platform
that's because of me guys I would like
literally people giving pennies and
whatever it was boop away from the
businesses and they're getting really
annoyed because I mean there's a little
girl like it was obnoxious I was loud
but like it drew attention from what
their businesses were right it's
interesting because you discover
yourself as a tomboy and you're
interested in things that you end up
having more guy friends than girlfriends
yeah kind of plays into the bullying
environment that I guess you were in but
at the same time you've got this want to
be a beauty queen type I'm innovating -
no but I thought you know I said it was
like it was just I think that I like to
do all the guy things but I've always
been this way like I like hair and I
like makeup but I'll go camping in a
heartbeat like that's just I think I
have a lot of interest so but I think
mentally like mentality why so even now
like my all my best friends are guys I
mean when eventually I do get married
all my bridesmaids are gonna be male
like it doesn't to be interesting
yeah and I think that I think that's
like that's not allowed
it's gonna it's gonna have to be I'm
sorry there I like that's how it's gonna
work I know I can wear dresses no like
just thinking where their suits and be
them Sassy's out like
themselves it's just you know it's just
how it's gonna work out okay so you said
you moved to Hollywood yeah at 18 yes so
as high school was finishing up why I
graduated a year early so I got an art
scholarship for drawing like it was so
fun I had an academic scholarship to
Northern Arizona University which is
slight staff but the last minute I got a
scholarship that was like partial
tuition to ASU and I was I don't know I
went with my gut and I'm like you know
what I'm not gonna do well in the cold
weather I'm gonna go to Arizona State so
I end up going to em ASU for two years
and so I'm sorry mention when I was 19 I
was turned 19 the month I moved here
moved in August okay so I was go I went
into college at 17 so that's rolling for
half a drawing so I was almost an art
classes the first year doing you know
all that stuff and but you didn't say
I'm a drawing major did you oh god no I
majored in drawing I know I was in the
arts dorm which is like it was called
McClintock and it's like this it's right
on campus and it's all it's all like
architecture students dance students
theater students and acting like you
know like multi theater and art and it
is the craziest party dorm on ASU it is
nuts and dramatic no oh my god like you
understand like people people someone
flooded the dorm one night where there
were like the rec area isn't lit toilet
paper on fire like stuff like that
happened on a weekly basis I got to the
point where I didn't get out of bed for
the fire alarms which is extremely
illegal because I was like I'm actually
happy to say I'm for class I mean I
can't deal with this I'm just gonna go
to sleep I feel the heat exactly this is
another false alarm it's just someone
else doing something something crazy see
fart see ya know the u.s. use the kind
of campus that you see like there's not
supposed to haze for like there for
their sororities and fraternities but
you see the naked people with a clown
things running down the middle of like
the figure out the name of the street
like all the time like you see the most
crazy stuff so at some point during this
process though you were like I don't
want to be a drawer I never I never
wanted to be I think that I always
wanted I always want to do acting but my
mom like you know wanted me to try
college and she's always been super
supportive but she's afraid just because
you guys know that's being in LA it's a
hard city to be in and I think she
didn't want me to be in an industry that
so so like so challenging and so
heartbreaking and she just wanted to
protect me from that so I think I just
prayed long enough and like one day she
woke up and she's like she realized she
said she's just something like God told
me was like you know I'm the one holding
her back and then she moment she told me
she's like just go to LA I moved like a
month after that like I wanted to leave
right then and there but I finished out
my finals and then and then moved but
after sophomore year mm-hmm yeah it was
right right after my finals and then she
gave you her blessing yeah and your dad
what about him oh he was always in my
dad's the cut was the kind of guy that
was like whatever you want just go for
it I support you like you know it sounds
great Brittany do it like that's my
mom's like well we need to think about
this like that the my mother
rip your dress punch him I'm sorry
exactly you wanna go to LA go to LA that
was my father that said what do you do
when you when you're 19 you're a 19 year
old girl and you're moving to Los
Angeles how does that work I always um I
always thought of it as like a business
where I came in
I came moved here with very much of the
business mentality I wasn't I had this
thing I was like I'm not here to make
friends I'm here to work so I I bought
this book called acting as everything
but Judy Kerr and I like bookmarked
every single little thing on it and I
got into classes right away so I was you
know I saved some money while I was in
college so I had I was taking seen study
classes and commercial classes and I
basically treated it like a business I
went to every single audition it didn't
matter what it was the figure it was
audition experience and I just I did
everything I possibly could I did like
tons of actor like you know that I
casting director workshops and I went to
producers a lot like I went to Busan
like Ugly Betty and go more girls and
Chuck and a bunch of shows some that
cast dirt you're seeing me and I get so
close if you tend to like the six people
because like what people don't
understand it it's like issues and then
there's like the like you're the
producer callback so the producer
callback that's like they've already had
ten thousand submissions they've been
probably auditioned a hundred people
they'll narrow it down to like six or
eight or four to bring two producers to
show them I would get so close on this
stuff and then not get it and it was
driving me so crazy so one day there was
this notice on now casting for this in
discomfort equator 11 and this guy named
I think his name was Josh Harris he took
his last three million dollars and he
created this company that was like live
video broadcasting and they were looking
for people that wanted to do their own
shows so I
at that point that I thought about my
cool well you know would it be funny if
I did this like clueless life coaching
character named Ron Anthony Tanner so I
went into that and pitch them my idea
and like made out with my hand and the
audition and like she's crazy we love
her so I started out with your made out
with my hand like I had a whole like the
whole spiel but like Rhonda's like
Rhonda kissing techniques or something
and like I'm literally made out with
Hannah in character and they were dying
laughing so it worked so I started doing
a show with them and then I think it was
I got up to like it was like at that
point this is before this is probably
eight years ago or nine years ago I was
getting like a hundred thousand hundred
thousand views an episode on my stuff
then what was that outlet again this was
caught as low as a live video
broadcasting company called operator
eleven and it was I got I came to work
one day and the doors were just can't
chain closed they ran out of money but
it wasn't it was a website yeah it was a
website yeah I was like oh like I don't
think of like um you know people they
have a live stream now it's cut it was
like one of the first kind of like live
stream Ustream blogtv type thing but I
did it in a different way I would pre
film all my sketches and I would go live
for a little bit but I would play my pre
film sketches so I turned it into kind
of like a show where I would do you know
I would intro and outro it but the
middle part was all pre done no you
still online somewhere I have the FLV
files and they're awful like it's not
like this is this is back in the day it
was this one still things for what for
320 by 240
oh yeah and like when we keep things out
we thought it looked really good and it
look awful this is like before you know
come on this is like I don't even know
if After Effects was out yet or like you
know everyone was doing stuff and final
cut like this is how you were getting
paid I was getting paid I was getting
paid some I to the extra money I did a
lot of promo modeling work which is oh
my god what is that it's it's so hard
it's basically like you on your feet for
15 18 hours a day and it's like you know
in closer like like you know how let's
say that you're like you got to like
anything like a volleyball event and
let's say there's Kellogg's is there and
they have a bunch like attractive people
walking around with like boxes of
Kellogg's like the new Syria that's
called promotional modeling so I
walking around a live event with toting
some sort of product yeah but what I
worked a lot of this because it's
perfect cuz I'm pasty white I did the
ABP Pro Tour
so for volleyball so likey that like
that goes all over or all the beaches
and that that out in the Sun so 15 hours
Bowl beach volleyball handing out
sunscreen samples for like 15 hours at a
time
well you're you're at all hi I'm short
in comparison to those people
I'm 6 feet yeah I mean yeah no but I
mean like I felt at home I was like oh
my god like this person in my life that
I'm short like her tall and beach
volleyball that's hard work it was it
was and they think the hardest part was
it took a while to get paid on stuff
sometimes to be like five months before
you get paid because it's not it's like
they that you get paid really well it
just take time to get paid so I also
worked out with my roommate where as a
dog walker so I would walk her dog I'll
get in exchange for money off my rent so
I get like $600 a month off my rent so I
did and then for all my classes I would
paint my like I painted my one teachers
fence I like I like what pole weeds I
take care of a house and it's gone like
I would literally work out with my
teachers where I would work for them to
be able to take lessons for cheaper so I
did anything you could possibly imagine
to pay the bills so the livestream job
started from just going to yet another
audition yeah yes you can at a certain
point you're just you said you were kind
of taking all auditions just to see what
would anything catch well cuz I mean
when I like this is not so much how it
is now but well I mean it might be but
like a lot of actors when they first
moved to LA will do a lot of student
films because sometimes those go to
festivals and they do well or they're
you know all the future you know
directors so I did a lot of student
films like when I finally did book one
with LA Film School ended up doing 18 in
a row yes because what happened is I
would be on set and then like someone
there would have their see the thesis
project coming up and look and I would
just hang up my cards to everybody and I
was like you know I was nice and I
worked hard and I did my stuff and I
left so I ended up doing like it was 18
in a row and I couldn't use one of them
cuz the footage was all terrible because
all students so yeah I did know I did a
couple for USC I did a couple AFI ones
just a lot of student films but the so
the livestreams thing how long did you
do that before you showed up and it was
just like doors or 6 months I worked my
butt off for 6 months like another thing
had on the on their thing I had like a
hundred thousand subscribe like
followers on the their site cuz I used
my space I would go on my space and I
would spent all day long talking to
people and I had this whole thing that I
was like well it's a character in
character people the name of the
character on to Anthony Tanner so it's
rat I was like Brad coaching I want
exterminate the pest from your life
thing so like but I mean my mom always
says if you can build an audience as
Rhonda it was a very weird character but
um that was right one lonely girl 15
like revealed that she wasn't a real
person to remember one that was was a
real person excuse me that's right when
I started you know she wasn't a real
person it was exactly yeah exactly so
the fact that she like you know was an
actress that's when that is when it all
blew up is when I started YouTube
because my mom's like well Brittany he's
just like that was really I was really
angry really upset because I put six
months of my life into this I thought I
finally had something going you know I
you know I thought like when you come to
LA it's very much worth like the
mentality of you need to take classes to
learn how to do anything I don't know if
you guys know that but like you need to
take a class to learn how to direct you
need to take a class to learn how to
write you can take a class only cuz it's
all there's no limits to the way you can
spend your money here you know this so I
think it was really good for me because
like people the studio taught me final
cut and then I bought a green screen I
just started writing so I almost got to
like become a filmmaker without having
to pay money or go to class or it's like
I got just to learn from doing it and
like that was the best possible
experience was just be able to just try
it and make mistakes and you started
your your first YouTube channel as this
character character yeah in 2007 that
was based on your mom's advice yeah she
was watching lonely girl yeah no she
just she's stuffing in the news because
that she's like Britney this girl is now
all you know getting TV stuff from her
YouTube channel like and I kept you know
what I kept hearing at the casting
director workshops it's like you have to
be you know co-star to get and guest our
roles you should be a guest star to get
any reoccurring or series regular you're
just getting a series regular roles
before you'll be up for pilots like they
had this whole pecking order and they
kept saying like you have to be anything
you have to be name you have to be a
name and I'm like well what if your name
online would that make a difference like
you know so I thought maybe if I created
something online I read this really
really good article by this constant
director named Bonnie Gillespie and
she's like you can either
chasing these directors and chasing this
cat director casting directors and
chasing these producers or you create
something and people come to you so that
really got me thinking I'm like okay I
needed you know I've been here in LA for
four years like busting my butt
nothing's major has happened like you've
gotten close on some things you know so
this was like this is like my shot to do
something what's the closest thing get
to we wouldn't would we know something
no I mean I just like just like a lot of
like it's just a lot of like at the time
they were big oh yeah there was there
was an NBC pilot that I got pretty close
on but they never ended up shooting it I
got cast as the girl and then it just
fell through so I mean that was like the
closest I got to anything so lonely girl
15 was the way in to start a YouTube
account for you yeah I literally I just
saw her like I was like okay like is she
you know maybe I create something online
that would open up doors it's like all I
like I just love acting so it's like you
know any any possible way like I'm the
kind of person like I'm willing to put
in the work and you guys to like I don't
care if I have to edit 20 you know 20
hours and two days or whatever it is I
mean as long as it's a good product and
you know I'm getting into like you know
do what I love and it's worth it
so you just the first thing you did was
you just move that character over hey
I've got a hundred thousand followers
yeah yeah I'm gonna start a YouTube
channel how did how was that transition
um it was started out where I like in
the first month I was getting about like
5,000 views and episode by month - I was
gonna like 10th I was in be using it
this was 2007 yeah yeah so then like
then on average my average then after
like you know I think it was I did that
when I used to respond to every single
message in comment like I literally got
a carpal tunnel in my wrist I was just
wanting like 8,000 comments a week I was
insane I turned to turn it in my fall
time job I was like I'm just gonna and
then the partner program came along and
I was like home y'all have you know I
think I had 3,000 subscribers when I
applied to the partner program and got
accepted and that was so nerve-wracking
just remember back then was like if you
were denied then you had to wait like
six months again to apply do you
remember that okay this is like it I
didn't know that's how it works yeah you
have to if you would they were denied
you had to wait six months to apply
again so when I applied I got accepted
knows like you have a YouTube partner
yeah so then I started doing the stuff
with Rhonda but then I was on that
channel for I think was about two years
and that's when I met Shane like Shane
was watching my Rhonda stuff and he
thought that I was actually Rhonda when
he found out that I was I think I put
out one that was like 10 facts about me
and I decided I would finally to show
people like and I think they did really
well on my mom my challenge like oh my
gosh she's acting but it was the same
Channel the same Channel so this was
like you saying this is a character
exactly and was that like a bombshell
for PETA was for shaming people not for
Shane it was like like this is Shane's
words not mine he's like oh my god she's
not [ __ ] like they're shades or as a
light so he was like he's like oh my god
so then like we I think we started
messaging each other back and forth cos
again I was watching I watched 50,000
videos in my first year like you know
YouTube used to track the video beauty
like it would show you know what amount
of videos yeah so I watched 50,000
videos in the first year because I was
leaving comments like just like I
figured I literally thought I mean the
best way to form a community is to go
out and you know like make friends and
watch stuff and be supportive and I
would leave really nice comments I give
someone a singing video be like oh my
god you were really good voice alright
did you invite the phrase sub4sub ask
your video watch mine it was no I never
did that
the only person ever got blocked by was
Bratz and Bretta YouTube space I'm like
you guys know you blocked my channel
because I used to go on every day onto
like lisanova and whatever and I'd leave
a comment on the channel page well you
went on our channel to probably I write
no I remember was it that I was at the
weird I photo yeah yeah I didn't like oh
gosh block you you don't remember this I
do never remember you could go to
someone's channel I'm still comment on
somebody's channel now but it's miss is
a front-and-center default thing the
latest person is comment on a channel
and a lot of people wouldn't do it so it
would stay up there awhile and you do it
a couple of times I was in character
exactly haremos yep oh yeah and I
thought you were
be rad yeah you write nice amazing it's
kind of embarrassing but not because it
was my past so like like I think I've
learned a lot I mean you know it's like
you used you see what works Shane
whenever you did that on Shane's channel
he had seen your videos or maybe him and
Kate used to watch my videos make fun of
me like that I was like you know Shane
o/s has that person that he loves to
watch for a laugh and I was the person
that he was watching oh my god she's
mentally insane so like we started
messaging each other back and forth it's
like memory you two had a share button
too and you're in character no this was
like this is after character I put out
that he contacted me after he's like
what oh my god he said he even till he's
like Kate she's a real person oh so um
we used to message each other back and
forth on actually MySpace this myspace
was still very prevalent then so he was
like I was a share button broken for you
and like yeah he's like we should hang
out sometime I'm like yeah so it was it
was Shane like I think he had that 25
thousand subscribers and he's been like
50,000 views an episode and I had 12,000
subscribers and he had 8,000 so that's
when we became friends he's like a small
Channel
so we met up at 3rd Street Promenade
with Kate and it was the first time I've
ever met anyone online like I don't do
that like that scares me like hey I just
knew we'd be like we talked online I'm
like he seems normal and I was kind of
hanging out with this like group of guys
that was just really strange I was like
I was like all of their in a strictly
platonic way I was like oh they're
treating me all like their girlfriend
and it was so strange I was like I need
to get out of this so I needed to make
some new friends like how specifically
were they treating you well they were
just like text me and call me all the
time and be like like super if like
flirty and it was just this whole group
of guys and it was weird it was just
really strange so I like I mean they
were dating all other girls but then
like like they would get jealous if I
was just really strange like I was like
I'm not dating you guys we're just all
friends what is going on so I ended up I
was like it was at that time and I
needed some new friends so Shane and I
think then we went Shane Kate and I went
to Six Flags and I remember we went to
Whole Foods later he's like I always
like oh could you ever play an email
character and I'm like yeah what do you
want me to say I'm just like really dry
like all throughout this dude mark
like brilliant so he wrote it and then
we didn't email break up and then that
that went pretty big and then we did how
to get big on YouTube and that and that
did I got big trouble with my roommate
cuz like Shane like filmed on her bed
one see like I did I like I kind of
talked into it but it's really funny now
we going to talk about it yeah so that
was white on her bed he filmed the video
it's like we're saying it no it's like
like he's he's doing something very
inappropriate to Joe nation on my bed
[Laughter]
yes
and then I'm she a co-worker told her
[Applause]
just really it was she wasn't the nicest
person but still I should have asked her
it was that was like one of my things
going back it was a guilt thing but it
was like wow things would be like I had
no money filming locations it was bad it
was bad so at some point in this process
you say okay it's time to kind of
develop my own identity
no Shane is the one that said you need
to stop being prodded you need to create
a new channel and either he's like if
she couldn't play other characters he's
like you should create a channel where
you play all different things so I was
like a whole light bulb like duh that's
what I should have dumped in the
beginning was like be myself and play
multiple things so he what year is this
um I think that was four years ago
four or five for my Brittani Louise
Taylor channel so then that's when I
start form that one so I think it was
because of him that I did it and the
four think the first video I uploaded
was like the emo breakup bloopers or
something like for the bloopers from our
video so so did you have a you know a
lot of success early on because you had
Shane he was growing in popularity who
was you know you were appearing in his
video so it was it you know I know yeah
then it was crazy I mean but before that
I'd been on YouTube for two and a half
years so like it wasn't like you know it
was really weird it for me I got really
excited when I got 50 subs a day like
that was big like you know I would my
goal was like 20 to 30 where I would try
to like you know make friends and I'm
like you know at that point
to keep like a graph I'm a person that
likes like notes and less okay oh yeah I
like 15 subscribers a J yeah that I
would keep write out every morning what
will my subscribers where am i doing our
own analytics in other words yeah yeah I
was so I don't you tube is nice enough
to make that graph for back you make it
you were doing the lines and everything
like wall yeah line graphing it mm-hmm
so I think that you know then when we do
wasn't really crazy but the thing is
like about Shane though he would kept
doing shoutouts and you tell people like
I remember I did a video Panasonic and
he told people to go say show me your
Tatas on my video but like so weird yeah
you told this is so literally have
50,000 comments of show me or yes and I
was like how do I explain this to
Panasonic because your your content what
is much cleaner like you won't say the
things that it's different yeah I think
that's what my friends were polar
opposites like that we are offices but
we both have good hearts but he's like
you know he's like dirty and we'll say
anything and I'm like oh I'm still like
a little child like I'm like my mom will
get mad at me well what kind of audience
have you built who are the I mean is it
is it girls watching you it's a
different audience and Shane in some
ways or I mean in some way I think that
you know I've picked up like but like
most fits from Shane so I have like my
audience it's like 83 or 84 percent
female I'm just like between the ages of
13 to 24 so I have always adorable
adorable young women like I would say at
VidCon like people get like you know
they'll come and they'll surround them
mine get in a line my the cute little
girls that get in the line and then very
polite like a boss it's like a [ __ ] mine
just lying high school I'd like you're
so cute like they all line up they don't
then they're patient they wait their
turn like they're so cute how does
knowing that that is your audience
impact what you create I think the best
thing for me is like when you start to
meet the people that watch your videos I
think anytime that you're tired or
you're like you know you've on your
fourth video that you're editing like
today where I'm like I've added four
videos today I'm like and I'm still like
off to go home and call her cooked and
do more just deadlines and a couple
things it's like when you meet the
people and then like there's just one
girl I met legislated Khan not too long
ago she was came up to me in line and
she's
start crying she's like you left a
comment saying I was beautiful and no
one's ever told me that I was beautiful
in my whole life and she's in some
gorgeous Asian woman and she's Korean
gorgeous it's like absolutely gorgeous
and I'm like no one had told her that
she was beautiful
like I just the fact that like me
leaving a comment and someone's video
could change their life like that like I
think for me like I just I love acting
so much and I love the people more so
like I don't know I've always been like
I don't really get all stressed out when
things happen with YouTube with numbers
or things break like as long as there's
someone watching like I just love the
kids and I think something that just a
casual viewer of yours may not realize
is how technical you are and your
approach that I mean you're you pretty
much do everything on your channel that
you do the music you may get someone to
produce it or sweetener or whatever yeah
I have I have editing and that is
something that I take on right I've been
I just started to hire own training and
she's brilliant I've been training
someone to help me just with editing on
like the beauty videos just because it's
just like you know an extra 8 videos a
month that I just need help on so but I
mean yeah I mean I write and produce and
pick up the props and film and do
everything and I made my favorite
technically-minded when it comes to
those things I love it though I love I
might like well I have some of my
friends that like oh I just wanted I
just want to act just one over whatever
and I'm like I love every part of the
filmmaking process I love the shot list
I love filming I love editing I love
acting
I love the whole I love the finished
product I just I love it I always say
I'll bleed for it if I'm passionate
about it let's do it I'm ready blade now
what point did or it has this point come
did you say okay well now I'm doing
YouTube I mean that's what that's what
my career is and that's what my career
goal is or is it is there still this
sort of side dream or bigger dream
beyond you to to be like okay I do want
to parlay this into an acting career you
know what's so funny like I do you have
you ever made like a goal she like of
goals that you have
well like okay well like read sheet to
write him down no but I did I mean I'll
find in feel guilty no but it's so weird
I would like literally found the sheet
that I wrote and I think I found it I'm
gonna post a couple months ago and it
was like reoccurring role on a TV show
and like I had that right now I'm like
I'm like a national TV commercial I'm
like I have that right now I'm like all
the things that
these things I've wrote and written down
I was like check a manager that believes
in me check and it's like it's I
realized at that moment that I'm like
I'm living my dream I get to do what I
love and I'm like I don't care if it the
project is on YouTube or it's a film or
it's a TV show
I don't care where it's that because I
feel like the lines are crossing like I
was in such a rush and wanted so badly
to break in TV and film when right now
TV and film wants to break into YouTube
like it's so strange like everything's
going online and right and I have no
desire to leave if anything I mean I
wrote an eight-episode web series we had
an offer for funding from one company it
wasn't enough money we have another
thing figure cross fingers cross that
we'll see if it comes through like for
me if anything I just want to keep you
know increasing the quality and things
would be a new channel what's the nature
of it I don't want to go into too much
this is a really good it's like it's
it'd be almost like a CW kind of show so
it's like it's a it's a like ten minute
webisodes there's eight of them and it's
very interactive and it's very it's what
my audience would like like you know it
has to do with like romance and love but
it's like it's really funny like the
characters are spirit each one's very
distinct and it's very funny so you're
playing a character I play the main the
main girl Samantha Samantha yeah and
just give us a little bit of what
Samantha's like what's the hook um I
think that the big well the big hook of
the series is the relationship between
her and her best friend because they're
perfect for each other he's in love with
her she doesn't realize it so it's like
that whole thing where you're always
rooting for them to get together and
then they finally do and then they don't
and then you know it's just all that but
it's like the I don't know this the
series I can I don't want to go into it
too I'm so I'm so paranoid I'm like
afraid the eight the first eight
episodes are written the first season is
done and I just you know I want to get
it made and get it out there so so it's
a question of sponsorship with enough
money to cover the budget I just haven't
like I just I thought about doing
Kickstarter but I have like I just admit
I have major issues of being like hey
give me $10,000 I'll give you a line in
my show you know something like I don't
want my kids money or my viewers money I
would rather you know get a sponsor
behind it or get you know I feel like
that's the route that I want to try I
mean I know is I might eventually if you
know try Kickstarter but I don't think I
want to I don't want you know I don't
want my viewers money to do something
that I want to do I'd rather it be free
for them and then
just you know be entertained and have to
deal with maybe a little bit sponsorship
in it know you've been doing this for
quite some time seven years yeah right
and you know and we have each other you
know this is not an easy this is not an
easy business to be in because we're
YouTube is constantly changing and you
can kind of reinvent yourself and come
up with new things and keep people
interested in that kind of thing you're
doing this kind of alone and you're
still doing it and you're still I mean
you're gonna leave from here and go and
edit more videos what keeps you
motivated what keeps you going I think
that it's just mentality like I get I
literally have to tell myself that like
you know that there's no like I watch
this really good sermon by this pastor
Joel Osteen he was talking about how
like you have to literally tell yourself
that like there's nothing that you can't
handle like get up and like just know
that whatever God gives you it doesn't
matter if you're religious or not but
like I'm a Jesus Freak so like they just
talked about how like you need to get up
and say that like you know thank you God
that whatever you give me today I know
that I can handle because you want to
given it to me if I couldn't have
handled it so on the day is when I'm
really tired I'm like okay well this is
on my plate so obviously I can handle it
so I think a lot of its just its
attitude instead of me when I'm home
editing instead of being like oh I'd
rather be out it's like oh look at what
I'm getting to do look at the products
and I mean I struggle with the changes
to YouTube because if he knows like the
trend is a lot of like you know put up
multiple videos that are lower quality
or it's like put up like a gaming video
or whatever and I just know for me like
that's not my style like I love making
really cool videos I want if anything in
what I just put up like a challenge be
with my brother a challenge with a
friend I'm like I feel like I'm letting
them down and they love it but I want
over-the-top I want like something
different you know like so it always
bothers me I love that video but yeah so
I think then it's just fun YouTube is
one of those places that like you know
it's always gonna keep changing and I
mean who knows if it's going to be
YouTube it might be another site in five
years I mean but I know I'm always gonna
be making my own content like once you
realize the power and freedom of doing
stuff yourself you'll never stop it's
like being your own boss it's brilliant
it's a pretty good deal I mean I get a
lot of people ask me like how do I get
big on YouTube and I'm like they're like
it's just hard work like some people hit
it on the first one some it's two years
so much for like what's the fine
brothers how many years was it for them
or they blew up was it seven or whatever
like then then now they're huge like you
can't like you have to put the work in
you know let I'm like get a camera learn
to film learn to edit like you know you
got to put in the work and then you know
if you want anything you just fight for
it well we appreciate hearing your story
of fighting for it and the success
you've had oh thanks for this time as
you spent with us grab the sharpie you
got to sign the table oh I do yeah okay
do you describe it like as I'm signing
it or how do we do this this is they're
listening right now yeah yeah maybe I
should go over that direction there's a
good yeah mistake charting new territory
over here oh yeah and that was our ear
biscuit with Brittani Louise Taylor
thank you - Brittany for sharing her
story you know the thing that struck me
was her sheer tenacity in creating her
YouTube presence how she was she had
something on that the live streaming
platform and interestingly enough she
had pre-taped segments that was you know
it was very youtube ish to do that to
take a live platform - but to have these
edited pieces and so she she actually
used something that was made for YouTube
and did it somewhere else which was made
more for live-streaming and also going
back eight or nine years and doing
anything that had hundreds of thousands
of people that who were interested in it
that that is just unheard of I ever talk
to anyone who has who had that kind of
success that long ago and then it was
shut down and she had to basically start
over on the YouTube platform and she did
it in in the Tunisia's way that she did
it first of all she did it in character
but then she stayed in character in the
comments like I totally forgotten that
she had commented on our channel man
enough do I remember it vividly remember
it like I mean I I thought I interpreted
her character as being
stalker like someone who's a little too
into what we were doing to reply to I
was a little concerned but she was in
character yeah it was the great thing
about it and she commented on everybody
that commented on her video and watching
fifty thousand videos and her first year
on YouTube I mean a the thing that it is
really significant to me is that you've
got people who kind of just stumble into
it you know we talked to glozell where
she makes the initial video that it's
sort of an accidental viral video and
it's and then her career becomes about
well building upon that moment you know
and it becomes a successful YouTube
career and then you get somebody like
Britney who just basically willed it
into into being and you know and I did I
know there's a lot of people out there
there's a lot of people listening a lot
of people you know in that now that this
is a thing that you can do who they want
to do it and you just see that well it
might be a whole lot of work you know
it's it's definitely that's not one of
the paths yeah I don't know that Britney
would say she should reply to every
person who commits on your videos but
hey you know that's that's one way to do
it I don't think she's capable of doing
that now with the the you know the the
quantity of comments on her channel I'm
sure she doesn't she's not able to do it
now but she still maintains that
personal connection that I mean she was
able to tell us about so again it's
great to get the perspective on how she
has made it to the place where she is
and we look forward to you know this
this narrative series that she's talking
about which seems like we got a little
bit of the scoop on that so that's good
that's what I ear biscuit will give you
the scoop it'll give you the scoop it'll
give you an understanding it'll help you
understand somebody now when we watch
our videos or when you watch our video
you're going to understand more of the
girl from Arizona maybe we should have
called this podcast the scoop that's
what I'm thinking sounds like it makes
it make a cat litter you know about ice
cream or ice cream the scoop kitty
litter ice cream now that's something to
think about
you've never had a cat what do you think
about a kitty litter with
I scoop I had a cat for a little bit if
we really want to go into I had a calico
kitten that I talked about that let's
not even kill it we just gave it back
give it back to his mom we'll get into
this later right thank you for listening
to this ear biscuit we do it every week
we have capacity for you to invite your
friends to listen via the SoundCloud or
the iTunes and please do that keep
listening keep inviting use both ears
and we'll keep broadcasting in mono you
keep listening in stereo we will reply
to your comments individually next week
links going to be in your left ear and
I'm gonna be hearing your right ear well
we'll talk about that maybe not well
it's possible yeah we could I mean
technically we could do that I'm gonna
try to make it happen see you next week
or you hear us next week something like
that bye
[Music]
[Music]